welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and Deadpool 3 is looking to be the
biggest movie of 2024 and now it's going
after every possible audience with
rumors that Taylor Swift may be joining
the cast as the mutant dazzler director
sea Levy played koi when asked about
these rumors but Taylor Swift was
spotted at a Chiefs game with Sean leevy
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman and it's
just impossible to not think something
may be going on here I could speculate
for days about the Nery aspect of this
movie but there is really a deeper
debate here about pop stars like Taylor
Swift and Harry Styles and yes they did
dat and she wrote songs about him pop
stars like this showing up in the MCU I
personally love it but many have said
that their Fame takes them out of the
moment others have said that's exactly
what we need them to do honestly when it
comes to all this I'm out of my depth we
decided that we need to go to the source
and talk to some real card carrying
swifties and because I am afraid to talk
to strangers in public we're doing
something different for this video and
we're going to throw it over to a friend
of the channel CM g a hilarious YouTuber
you might know from Epic Rap Battles G4
ton of other stuff he's amazing and he
got to the bottom of the discourse
around Taylor Swift joining the MCU I am
excited and terrified to see what he
learned take it away cm look who's
matter match man yes sir here with
corporate yeah you can say we're here
with corporate yeah are you or not no
hello everyone it's me new rockars
Resident Marvel rumor scooper can I get
double fries with that today we're
giving people the news that Taylor Swift
has indeed been cast in the MCU a
billionaire taking jobs for millionaire
actors let's find out what people have
to say Taylor Swift you guys Taylor
Swift fans are you swifties I have
decided and concluded that Taylor Swift
is in the MCU because she's with you
know who that is I am Jackman Wolverine
Green Lantern um and Taylor Swift Green
Lantern yeah that's nice right oh yeah
yeah yeah wrong it's terrible okay the
guy from blade I think as well he's also
in Blade yeah let's keep her out guys
let's keep Taylor out of the MCU could
you even picture her as Professor X I
could not no no that's horrible that's
horrible it would be interesting it
would be interesting sure but
unfortunately we need more than just
interesting when it comes to hits on top
of hits on Billboard charts like that's
Taylor Swift bro I've been hearing her
since I was little on the car radio guys
Taylor Swift yes or no no can you do
your best Professor X for me right now
my best Professor X
um let's see make sure you're in the
chair oh yes okay there's something
about this that really works for me I
see we must find New Mutants to enroll
into our AC Academy honestly so much
better than anything Taylor could have
done Beast galatis yeah no one know what
if I told you she's the new Kang isn't
Kang a I have no idea oh I don't think
so modok I could see her as modok did
you see what the the last modok looked
like in the movie much different Ghost
Rider maybe you know the the similarity
between Ghost Rider and Taylor is that
they both made a deal with with the
devil huh see that billboard up there
John already got Taylor Swift's face on
it they waste no time I don't think
she'll be in it because of how big she
is and she doesn't need it she doesn't
need the money she doesn't need the fame
do you like Marvel movies I think
they're cool yeah do you have a favorite
hero uh I think Superman okay that would
be DC but Spider-Man Spider-Man
Spider-Man maybe Spider-Man Spider-Man
out of all the photos we didn't get a
Spider-Man one I am such an idiot
Spider-Man Spider-Man guess what Taylor
Swift is the new Spider-Man n get out of
here it's frecked up right yeah you want
to sign a petition to make sure she
doesn't keep this
job we are the fans and we have the last
say right we're the ones that got John
cinski in the last uh Doctor Strange
movie as Reed Richards you and I have an
equal say and an equal vote when it
comes to who gets cast because we're
fans
right can I get your
signature sadly no because I have to go
you have to go good luck let's keep her
out let's keep her out of our favorite
movies five signatures so far you hear
that Taylor the people aren't happy with
you he
boys I'm going to stop saying hey boys
look at this these are all the people
she's dated in the MCU already oh wow
you know who these guys are I know him
yes Harry sty Harry Styles you know he's
in the MCU I don't think Harry Styles
should be in the MCU though to be fair
why that just the same reason you don't
want Taylor in it like he's also a
musician yeah but he's so goodl looking
um do you think the the addition of a
Taylor Swift would help or hurt I think
it would help the football fans cuz
maybe she's too busy to get to the games
cuz I'm tired of watching football and
they're cutting to her
so we want to watch football and not
swifties please do you think how long do
you think this dating thing is going to
like the soonest Travis Kelsey's stock
starts to drop it's done ter Swift needs
to figure out after all these breakup
songs and might be you
sweetheart I mean with the X-Men coming
in I've heard rumors what'd you hear
because I'm a rumor guy I spread rumors
and lies heard about a
dazzler that might be a thing so what's
who's who's dazzler so she's like an
X-Men that can uh do like sparkle things
huh o that actually that actually could
be perfect yeah she's taking over the
theaters now do she have a movie out
yeah it's right now in the Chinese
Theater
I think we should uh should probably go
see the arrows tour tiny theaters right
across the street here maybe we should
go Ground Zero the Lion's Den where all
the swifties are right in the center
right in the center of it look who's met
match yes
sirate yeah you could say we're here
with corporate yeah are you or not no
we're we're here to talk about Taylor
Swift you could talk whatever you you're
fre are you a fan or I don't I don't
really
care honestly she got are you a marble
fan she got hired she got C
I would it's
good are you a Taylor okay okay okay
she's got her goons everywhere that's
why I asked we've been physically moved
to the sidewalk are you a Swifty first
of all you got to level with first of
all no okay but I do own the original
suit that Ryan reynolds's screen test
was done in you're a Swifty maybe yes
you you think this is all okay excellent
that is excellent which one the duck
beak is particularly excellent you like
that one yes that's fantastic so I'm not
going to get you to sign this petition
to keep Taylor out of the MCU you know
the more it's beat to you the more I
think she should be in it wow I'm going
to listen to it let me see what this
Taylor Swift is play Taylor Swift top
songs on Spotify do you not think though
this is may be controversial okay think
that a lot the Marvel stuff is like done
now oh
okay
oh this song's Taylor Swift the more you
speak to me the more I think she should
be in it well there we go happy to
help yes yes absolutely perfect so how
long have you been a Swifty uh it's been
about 15 seconds now you know I started
the day not knowing a whole lot about
Taylor Swift I'm not above admitting I
was
[Music]
wrong let's get her
[Applause]
[Music]
in